без прапора без команди та без капітана
ляльки тату різко судно кантон стояти біля
християнському порту стискаєш і pewter
оракул 2014 унцій монтажний корабель
заходивши догоду анексованого криму а
пісні подружжя до порту материкової
україни тут за рішенням суду та й ви
заарештували з обвалення сантів судну
голосних пуканів команду на що дозволяє
але судновласником з однокласниками
новим екіпажу треба не води і до нас
повернувся консул довідка їм щоб ми
зняли екіпаж судна і направлено берег
то судно було на каравани по суті було
некеровані поручи з турецькою
вітрильником стоїте український букси
рвіться вид також незаконно адже виду
вів окупований крим
залом же заданому генпрокуратури
україни за розраховувала чотири судна за
підвищення санкцій разів рег рег трьох річок
майже всі десяточки турові чехії наші
клієнти
клієнтами андрей клименка жердина голок його
називають судно вітрило на київ і стос
трабли до його чорного списку експерт
майдану за кордон нас має рацію ж два з
половиною уроку ще дня в d моніторинг
всіх судан і ківі рухати крим після
анексії
за зараз венера пулів 260 вітрильників
санте
знак 51 з суден мають обидва види ніж
немає України з частини наці кораблів
перестала плавати до криму шукай обидва будуть
продані русі
тягар висловився і титрують компанії
ручки будувати компанії гречки з пара хіт
судно спить прапор укриття під якусь 100
вирахуванням заміню чим він волі і немає nozbe
значить і роблять
decker вразила мета переліт не
приковувати свої нас ви пропали flash
та 2 болгарських танками
місяця видосик спорту і this сторони as is
криму акривних три грецьких то цим
румунських судан і до six por tu es
острову металобрухт те зерно, що правда
пити прапор марі знак край НДП вдалося
через це сила 6 представлена ​​кама
румунських суду in te своєї провини не ви
знаєте ось знову ціни наші судно
я ще ви по рівер це наш сайт про обидва
читаєте у нас немає їжджу одного судна
мити чи кіно дай йому обслуговування
судном у константі та румунія повз нього
контракт з подання цик суду на
ківі 2 дмуть крим ми представляємо і поїхав
ще в раму немає шукайте судно виходьте з
наших у порту що ми вже завдали amazon їх
це не так break apart
андрей клименко тим словам верина ними
заповнюючого було вже дістань його
розслідування які дублі форму на бенкеті
формули судно через офшори і ходити на
їх ду криму на думку експерта україна
травні 2000 тут їх судан біля портів румунії
rated а болгарії тим часом за ростова на
турецьке судно в Херсоні і приносить
україні лише надлишку через витрати на
ранок мене судно владних на зв'язок
не виходьте